For this next problem, imagine you're the captain of a ship on the high seas.
And you know there's some enemy ship about 200 m away.
You want to aim your cannon at some angle α,
and shoot the cannonball with some initial velocity of v¬ such that you hit the enemy ship.
Unfortunately, there's this 40-m tall iceberg about 110 m away from you,
which makes your shot a lot more difficult because you have to go over the iceberg.
So what angle α and initial speed v¬ should you use such that you hit the enemy ship?
Now, there are actually a lot of answers here.
But we're just looking for one that works. The one that works will hit the enemy ship.
And not hit the iceberg.
To answer this question, we're going to use a slightly different form of input than we normally do.
This one though here contains a computer code, and you may have used this one though before
if you've taken a Computer Science class at Udacity.
We're only going to focus on these two numbers here. These two are the important ones.
You don't need to worry about this line up here and this line down here.
You will only need to look at these two, and you're going to take this line initial velocity = 50,
and replace the 50 with what you want your initial velocity to be.
So if you wanted your initial velocity to be 60 m/s, then you replace the 50 with a 60.
You don't need to include the units.
And if you wanted the launch angle to be 20°, then you need to replace this 10 with 20.
Again, you don't need to write the word degrees or anything like that.
So once you're ready to fire the cannon with this initial velocity and this launch angle,
go down here and press the run button.
Though after you press run, you'll be able to scroll down and see a nice graph
of what the trajectory of your cannonball looked like.
So I've scrolled down and now I get this nice graph of my cannonball's trajectory.
And as you can tell, it looked like it was doing all right.
It was headed towards the ship, but unfortunately it hit the iceberg.
So next time I'm going to have to aim either a bit higher
or give it a bit more oomph to try and hit the enemy ship.
So feel free to toy around with your values and try and hit the ship just by guess and check.
Or you can solve it directly and then hit the ship that way.
Either way, once you've hit the ship, you'll get this nice boom animation,
and then you know you have the answer.
So once you've hit the enemy ship, you should scroll up
and then press submit to submit your homework for grading.
Now, currently, my cannonball doesn't work quite right because it hits the iceberg
so I get this try again message but once you hit the ship you should get a "you got it correct" message.
In that way, you know your homework's been counted.